the Sun beats down relentlessly on the
parched landscape here in eastern
Somaliland we see the signs of the
drought everywhere we look this river
has been dry for two years and the
further we travel the stronger the
stench of decay Abdullahi by now has
watched his animals die one after the
other
he had forty camels and fifty goats and
sheep now all he has left is six goats
it's everything he has in the world and
all he has to sustain his family before
we used to sell the animals and buy food
and water and clothes for the kids but
now all my animals are dead we've lost
everything I've never experienced
anything like it we've been through
droughts in the past but this one has
left us with nothing de la Habana has
walked over a hundred kilometers in
search of water and food but it hasn't
rained here for two years
his family have run out of energy to go
on all abdullah Habanos wife can offer
her family as a single kilo of flour a
neighbor took pity on them but they
don't have any water so are unable to
cook when we still have animals I could
get the children a milk and butter but
now we have nothing but dry flour I have
nothing else I know that my children
will get a stomachache from this
especially my little one they're very
worried about their children but they
can't afford the bus to get to the
hospital in the city all they can do is
sit under this tree pray and wait for
rain
in the village a local aid organization
hands out money to the elders so that
they can divide it out among the
families $85 per person the aid
organization is trying something new
money instead of flour because those who
are suffering know what they really need
but there's not enough money available
and more and more people need support
when we arrive at the next village the
crowd gathers there hoping that aid
workers have brought them something it's
tough for those working here too it's
very heartbreaking it's very sad to see
this
we gives most small aid to them because
the aid we find from the international
community is so little so far and if we
didn't respond well to this rotten
situation we are afraid of a famine one
reason for the lack of international aid
is that 26 years ago
Somaliland declared independence from
its crisis-ridden neighbor Somalia
Somali land is peaceful and stable but
no one recognizes its independence so it
receives little aid from outside
meanwhile more and more people displaced
by drought arrived in the villages the
Somaliland government refuses to set up
camps it fears the spreading of disease
and terrorism
so villagers bear the burden the
displaced people are all living with
other families our villages phone we're
stacked up on top of each other in the
huts and it's not like we had anything
before what will they do we ask what
should we do if it doesn't rain soon
that would be the end of our lives on
this earth
death is never far away in Borel
hospital - especially for the many
children suffering from malnutrition
most of them also have pneumonia measles
or diarrhea illnesses which can be fatal
for their weak state a Yan Li is also
fighting for survival he was abandoned
by his family left in one of the drought
villages saddled a hare took him in and
has been in hospital with him for 26
days half of his life she's named him a
Yan Li lucky man the international
community does not count those who died
because of other diseases that are not
related they don't count them as
starvation or a famine but as a matter
of fact this is a draught related death
the only pediatrician here is a Syrian
refugee it's a relief to have him here
says clinic director Ali supplies are
few and far between even though the
hospital is the largest in the whole
drought stricken region serving two
million people Somaliland is one of the
poorest regions on earth
it needs livestock to survive but this
livestock market is empty seventy-five
percent of its revenue comes from export
taxes on animals before the drought
around seventy thousand livestock were
exported every month says nashwa Alka
believe now most dealers have closed
down I had 50 employees now I only have
12 this drought is an economic disaster
for Somaliland if it continues we'll
have to shut down too many her sense
that they're too dependent on breeding
livestock Abdullah Heba now has decided
that if they survive the drought his
children will go to school to give them
the possibility of a different future
but first they all do have to survive
and that will only happen with more aid